and maybe
Marjorie Taylor green should take a page
out of the Playbook of Alexandria
ocasio-cortez because the same hearing
the very same hearing she was there to
set an example for Marjorie Taylor green
and the rest of these nuts uh on how to
actually question and how to actually
investigate and how to actually do your
job of oversight
questioning the same man
AOC is actually getting to the bottom of
actual fraud waste and abuse that is
egregious and should be investigated
whether it's in a Republican state or
whether it's in a Democrat state
watch this
is there any methodology you can think
of that would just result in
Pennsylvania and New York and California
being under investigation by this
committee well I I would defer to the
committee I don't really know what their
their objectives were in that case and I
I don't think I understand yeah um
um according to this report to prac for
example Arizona paid 1.6 billion dollars
to individuals to stolen identities to
get unemployment insurance benefits
Louisiana dispersed more than one
million to individuals after the date of
their death and in Kentucky
state employees applied for unemployment
benefits while still employed by the
state and were able to hack the state's
information management system and remove
holds on their own accounts and none of
these states
have been put under investigation by
this committee I find it very
interesting because as was stated at the
beginning the bipartisan nature of
oversight is what gives it its power
and what we are seeing are
investigations uh into and I believe
that that the methodology for these
three states is Highly Questionable and
I ask for this committee if we're going
to perform oversight then let's perform
oversight Congressional Democrats are
ready to perform that oversight and help
our constituents get the benefits they
need to pay their bills and I think that
there's no shortage of members of this
committee who are willing to stand up to
their own party when it's necessary but
I cannot for the life of me understand
why the majority would send these three
letters just to these three states that
leave us with no other conclusion that
there may be some rank partisanship in
this investigation committee Republicans
uh I ask you know if we're going to
start off let's do it right that is a
master class that should be taken into
account by every one of these dum-dum
Republicans and put into practice in
their own uh operation of their job
the fact that Pennsylvania New York and
California are under the watchful gaze
of the uh the house oversight and
accountability committee yet Kentucky
the home state of the chairman of this
committee James Comer is
laughable
that
they were paying state employees who
were still working unemployment benefits
and allowed them and look
Kentucky has a Democratic governor
and what Alexandria ocasio-cortez is
saying here is it doesn't matter if
we're going to be investigating
corruption let's investigate corruption
let's let's investigate the misuse and
fraud and waste and abuse of taxpayer
dollars that were meant for a noble
purpose during a global pandemic that
rocked the planet
but instead they're ignoring Arizona
they're ignoring Louisiana they're
ignoring they're ignoring every other
state
the other 47 States and territories and
the District of Columbia where we have
no representation
again Republicans not doing their job
because they're not there to accomplish
anything other than chaos other than
investigations it's Benghazi Benghazi
Benghazi Benghazi Benghazi all over
again except they're using a different
word
because they're not there to accomplish
anything they're not there to get
anything done for the American people
and it's pointed out expertly
masterfully
by Alexandria ocasio-cortez
I am Jesse dollimore I'd love to have
you subscribe to my YouTube channel just
search my name Jesse dollar more follow
me on social media I am at Dollar Moore
on Instagram Twitter and Tick Tock and
you can listen to my twice weekly
podcast co-hosted by myself and Brittany
page it's called I doubt it and it's
everywhere that you find podcasts